let's see if we can use our example to
understand the three types of income
statements and hopefully understanding
those income statements will also help
us understand this example so I'm going
to start off we're going to focus on
month two and what I've done is that
just rewritten some of this accrual
income statement down here so it really
looks like a statement so this right
here is the income statement for one for
month two on an accrual basis in that
month we said we had four hundred
dollars of revenue two hundred dollars
of expense
four hundred minus two hundred gives us
two hundred dollars of income an income
statement tells us what happened over a
period of time what was the activity how
much revenue how much expenses and other
things this is just a super simplified
one without taxes without interest
without other types of expenses over
here I also have drawn the balance sheet
at the end of month one and the balance
sheet at the end of month two or you
could also view this balance sheet here
as the balance sheet the beginning of
month two and the main thing to realize
this income statement tells you what
happens over time period while balance
sheets are snapshots or their pictures
at a given moment snapshots so this
tells us essentially what did I have the
assets are are the things that can give
me future benefits so what do I have and
the liabilities are things that I have
to give future benefit to or things that
I owe so this is what I have this is
what I owe and then the equity is what I
really have to my name if I net out the
liabilities to from the assets so at the
beginning of the of month two which is
the end of month one I had $100 of cash
no accounts receivables I didn't owe
anyone anything I didn't know the money
I didn't know them services so 100 minus
zero means I had $100 that's kind of
what the owners of the companies can say
they have a value at the beginning of
the month you fast forward now at the
end of month two I now owe the bank $100
so I just put this as negative $100 here
normally wouldn't be accounted that way
and on an actual company's balance sheet
but this is simplified I had now but I
have an accounts receivable of $400 so
my total assets now are three
hundred dollars of assets and remember
accounts receivables are an asset
because someone owes me something
someone owes me cash in the future I
still have no liabilities so you take
all of your assets - all of your
liabilities and now I have $300 in
equity so you can see the snapshot at
the beginning of the month 100 in equity
snapshot at the end of the month 300 in
equity and so to go from one point to
the other to go from 100 to 300 I must
have grown in equity by 200 I must have
gotten $200 worth of value from
someplace and that's what the income
statement describes it describes it
right over here the change in equity
sometimes the change in returned
earnings or our or just change in equity
that is going to be the $200 in net
income that the company got over that
time period now there's one thing that
you're probably confused by right now is
like well you know how do we reconcile
everything with the cash we know that
over this period we got $200 in income
on an accrual basis but when you look at
the cash we went from $100 positive cash
to negative $100 in cash it looks like
we lost $200 so how can we reconcile the
fact that we got $200 in income how can
we reconcile that with the fact that we
lost $200 in cash and that
reconciliation is going to be done on
the cash flow statement and I'll do that
in the next video